hundreds of trucks are stranded at the
main border crossing between Pakistan
and Afghanistan after gun battles
between Security Forces on Wednesday
trucks are backed up for kilometers on
both sides of the Border waiting to
cross the security situation remains
tense Pakistani government and military
officials say they are in contact with
Afghan authorities to try and defuse
tensions Let's cross to our
correspondent Kamal Haider who is at
that talk and border crossing for us
good to see you Kamal so firstly tell us
what the situation is at the border
right now and remind us why this uh
situation situation has arisen
well first of all as you can see this is
a Meandering road that passes through
the Khyber Pass it then reaches the
token border region which is just a few
hundred meters from where we are this is
of course a Lifeline for Afghanistan and
every time there are tensions On the
Border it is the Traders and the truck
drivers who suffer the most there are
hundreds of trucks on the Pakistani side
that are carrying perhaps non-perishable
items but the trucks on The Afghan side
are carrying grapes Tomatoes garlic
vegetables and other fruits and those of
course are going to be lost if this
continues any longer now the recent
Crisis began after the Afghans decided
that in the Afghan Taliban decided to
set up a new post according to the
pakistanis this was in no man's land
both countries have their positions
already established on this border so
there was an objection from the
Pakistani side after which the
pakistanis said the Afghan Taliban
authorities their forces started to
fight across the border at the Pakistani
positions and the pakistanis retaliated
with that fire two people injured on
this side no confirmation on any
casualties on the other side but it was
that the Skirmish which lasted for
almost an hour that brought things to a
grinding Halt and so now you see trucks
on both sides people who want to cross
over to Afghanistan patients who are
coming from Afghanistan Ordinary People
now all suffering because of this
closure as you say this is the main
border crossing between Pakistan
Afghanistan a Lifeline where do you see
this going because this Border close
closure has happened before
yes there have been several locations
where the Border closes after tensions
between the two sides however then it
reopens after negotiations
neither side can afford to prolong this
because it is a loss not just for the
pakistanis but for the Afghans living on
the other side as well both countries
need to improve that relationship
because Pakistan cannot afford to have
bad relations on its western border
because it also has to contend with the
eastern border where its relations with
India are not very good so this is
indeed crucial but at the end of the day
such incidents cause a lot of damage uh
lots of Revenue on both sides and both
sides of course both countries have a
economic crisis they're not doing too
well so such incidents not helping in
any way however there is expectation
that once again the two sides will
realize that it is a nobody's interest
nobody
gains anything from this and so
everybody will be hoping that the Border
should reopen within the next few days
if not weeks thank you for that Kamal
Haider at the talk and border crossing